the Lord is the consciousness that
exists for itself but no longer merely
the notion of such a consciousness
rather it is a consciousness existing
for itself which is mediated with itself
through another consciousness that is
through a consciousness whose nature it
is to be bound up with an existence that
is independent or thing hood in general
the Lord puts himself into relation with
both of these moments to a thing as such
the object of desire and to the
consciousness for which thing hood is
the essential characteristic and since
he is a quad the notion of
self-consciousness and immediate
relation of being for self but be is now
at the same time mediation or a being
for self which is for itself only
through another he is related a
immediately to both and be mediate to
mediate idli to each through the other
the Lord relates himself mediate to lead
to the bondsman through a being a thing
that is independent for it is Justice
which holds the bondsman in bondage it
is as chain from which she could not
break free of the struggle thus proving
himself to be dependent to possess his
independence and thing good but the Lord
is the power over this thing for he
proved in the struggle that it is
something merely negative since he is
the power over this thing and this again
is the power over the other it follows
that he holds the other in subjection
equally the Lord relates himself
mediated ly to the thing through the
bondsman the bondsman quash
self-consciousness in general also
relates himself negatively to the thing
and takes away its independence but at
the same time the thing is independent
visa via the bonds but whose negating of
it therefore cannot go the length of
being altogether done with to the point
of annihilation in other words he only
works on it for the Lord on the other
hand the immediate relation becomes
through this mediation the sheer
negation of the thing or the enjoyment
of it what desire has failed to achieve
he
succeeds in doing that is to have done
with the thing all together and to
achieve satisfaction in the enjoyment of
it desire failed to do this because of
the things independence but the Lord who
has interposed the bondsmen between it
and himself takes himself only the
dependent aspect of the thing and has
the pure enjoyment of it the aspect of
its independence he leaves to the
bondsman who works on it
as we proceed now into paragraph 190
which is a very important turning point
we are entering the master-slave
dialectic proper that is we are now
seeing the determinate configuration of
the relationship between the master or
the Lord the hair and the slave the the
bondsman the connect in in Germany even
you notice I've got this triatic scheme
up here which Hegel is working through
in this paragraph and which is going to
be absolutely central for the rest of
what is going to develop I also you have
some some examples of different ways in
which the master can put the slave to
work different types of objects or or
fields in which the slave is going to be
doing something productive and I think
that it can be useful for us to think
about how these might themselves play
out in relation to this schema so Hegel
says the Lord is is the consciousness
that exists for itself it's self
consciousness existing for itself
remember it's gone through this struggle
to the death with the other self
consciousness who gave in who was
unwilling to sacrifice or even to fully
risk its life and therefore ended up
trembling ended up giving in ended up
not going all the way the master was
willing to depart from this life willing
to put their life entirely on the line
and as a result was able to now reap the
benefits of the relationship that this
is going to afford to them so he says
the lure is the consciousness that
exists for itself it's no longer just
the notion of such self consciousness
all the development that we've been
seeing self consciousness go through up
until this point has been working
through this notion this big riff of
what it means to be a self consciousness
Hegel by the way is not saying that
although self consciousness or all of
Spirit fits into master and slave but
this isn't a
central moment in the development that's
taking place so now we're seeing
self-consciousness become concrete that
is it takes a determinate form we could
think of this as you know the many
different cultures that have had
relations of slavery or a servitude you
know that is a determinate shape where
you have a master and you have a slave
but even more importantly you also have
things upon which the slaves were if you
don't have this third term in the
picture none of this was going to really
matter so he says it's it's a
consciousness that exists for itself
which is mediated with itself through
another consciousness so the master is
in fact mediated through the servant
through the slave the master you know
doesn't have absolute existence in and
for him or herself as something totally
out there totally independent the way
that that servitude has been depicted in
other philosophers who talked about this
might have given that impression for
example when Aristotle talks about
slavery and politics but one which I've
referenced already before he talks about
the master as somebody who is existing
or who has their being on their own they
are in Hegelian terms for themselves
Aristotle thinks about just in terms of
a kind of independence and the slave is
like Hegel is gonna say dependent the
slave is literally for in aerosol terms
cross in relation to the master they
don't have their human being they're
distinctively human being in the way
that the master does so let's go on he
says it's mediated with itself through
another consciousness that is to
reconnaissance whose nature is to be
bound up with an existence that is
independent or with thing hood in
general so the master does have a
relationship two things to think of to
this entire range in environment things
that are not self consciousness things
that are not themselves human but the
master has their relationship to those
things in a different way than the slave
does the slave is the go-between the the
one who is going to do things for the
master who is going to work on things
from the master who's going to change
them who's going to put them into a
different state which the master then
can consume so if we go on from there he
says the Lord puts himself into relation
with both of these moments and you
notice I've got all these arrows drawn
here the the Lord really is the center
of things the master is the one who is
determinative who sets the agenda so to
speak and you might say well they're not
really setting the agenda because it's
just their desires that are doing so or
or instincts or you know whenever you
like but as far as Hegel is concerned at
this point it's the Lord with whom the
initiative of the dialectical process is
residing with the the Lord
like I said sets the agenda the Lord
decides what things the slave is going
to work upon and sets the slave into
motion again it can be useful here to
think in terms of Aristotle's classic
treatment of slavery he calls the slave
a we might translate it as a tool that
possesses the soul and what that means
it's a tool it's an organizer that
possesses an internal principle of self
motion
it requires the master to actually
decide for the slave what that what that
shape of motion is going to look like
but the slave does have an aspect of
Independence if the slave is a human
being the slate is a self consciousness
and without
those kind of tools Aristotle thought we
really can't get the things that we need
done done this is why Aristotle thought
that slavery was in a certain respect
natural of course the way that he
understood natural slavery would
actually preclude much of the historical
forms of slavery has taken because you
have to have a master who actually
deserves to be a master when the slave
can't just be some poor schmuck who
happened to be in the wrong place at the
wrong time like a war captive Aristotle
talks about why war captives shouldn't
be slaves the slating has to be somebody
for whom it actually is to their benefit
to be in a position where somebody else
is calling the shots where somebody else
the greek term for that is arcane that
we translate us to rule but it can also
mean to determine to decide so when you
think about it this way the slave is in
this position where the master is
organizing the world in which both of
them live so he goes out and he says the
Lord puts himself into relation with
both these moments to a thing as such
the thing that they want which is the
object of desire and the so on that
desire played a very important role in
self consciousness self consciousness in
a certain way is desire the Lord wants
things out of the the big wide world and
the Lord is going to get those things
but the Lord is going to get those not
by himself or herself immediately
pursuing them or working upon them but
by making another self consciousness do
that work for them so he says the Lord
puts himself into relationship with the
thing into the consciousness for which
thing hood is the essential
characteristic now why is thing hood the
essential characteristic for the slave
here's where we ought to think quite a
bit about something going beyond the
mere property relation you know in
certain conceptions of servitude slaves
has been understood as a piece of proper
the thing itself is understood as the
property of the Lord you know there are
there are sort of labor theories of
value that that can work out this part
and Hegel is getting to something even
more basic than that he's saying that
the person who's who's stuck in the role
of being the slave the servant the
bondsman the connect in cables German is
in a position where they are in effect
being treated as a thing and also being
treated as not a thing or if you like
they're being treated as a thing taken
to a higher power a thing that is able
to do what other things cannot do here
again it's useful to think about
Aristotle Aristotle had this passage
that I've brought up before where he
talks about you know we're going to need
slaves until we have tools that can run
themselves so if we had shuttles that
could weave by themselves if we had you
know other things that would do their
own work we wouldn't need slaves to do
all that work Hegel is approaching this
idea but sort of from the other side of
it he's saying it's in the nature of
this relationship it's not in the nature
of the slave and slave but it's in the
nature of slave as social role within
this this whole matrix to be the one who
can work upon the thing who can
translate the will of the master into
actuality so this is all you know very
interesting and very important but what
does this lead to
he says since he is he's psyching about
the master quad the notion of self
consciousness an immediate relation of
being for self but now is it the same
time mediation or being for self who is
only through another he is related
immediately to both that's why I drew
these arrows here and me
to both the master is the one who not
only owns but determines the world
determines the the way in which things
are going to be for the slave a person
who's being understood in a thing leeway
and for the thing the non personal
objects of desire and for the master of
enjoyment as well so he goes on and he
says he's related immediately to both
but also immediately to both through the
other so it's not just that the thing is
related to the master through the slave
that is also a case right but the slave
is related to the master through the
thing the slave only exists as slave if
the slave is being set to do some kind
of work that the master himself or
herself would prefer not to do and would
like to reap the benefits over or cut
off the cream so to speak so this is a
very important point it's not just that
you have an object here which the master
wants to have some sort of relation to
and the slave is a means to that the
very meaning of the slave as a social
role as a position that a person can can
occupy is being provided by the thing
this this looks ahead to the passages
that are yet to come
where it's going to turn out that the
thing is going to be what allows the
slated to have a kind of consciousness
an understanding of self-consciousness
that the master himself or herself will
not actually enjoy so he says the Lord
it relates himself immediately to the
bondsmen through a being a thing that is
independent the thing that they want is
independent of our human desires it's
part of our human world but it's there
as some
that's not human as an object for us so
here's where it can actually be useful
to think about these examples so the
thing in terms of food production we'll
think about agriculture right you have a
feel first the field has to be plowed
who is going to do the plowing
it's not going to be the master the
master might supervise right but the
master is not going to get his or her
hands dirty
with that kind of muck who's going to
cultivate the field
who's going to plant the seeds who's
going to do the work of weeding who is
going to bring in the harvest who is
going to do whatever processing has to
be done you know think about grain grain
you have to get rid of the bran or the
husks and then you have just the seeds
that you want you know other things have
to be stored in certain ways they have
to be preserved many foodstuffs have to
be cooked in certain ways all that is
taking the thing which is an object of
desire for both the slave and the master
qua human beings and having the slave
work upon them so the master can do it
what about manufacturing there we've got
a a more involved kind of process where
you're taking something you know a good
example of this would be in the ancient
world they discovered that if you heat
it up sand in the right ways you could
actually produce glass and glass was
something that was a high value item it
wasn't great glass compared to the stuff
that we can now do today but it was
pretty cool nonetheless and for that you
need people who are going to go out and
do what we call the grunt work sit
around in a hot area shovel sand work
with these things that can be sometimes
dangerous within a household household
management is the Greek word for that is
what we get the word economy from what
could no maintain and many servants were
set to tasks within a household in our
modern culture today are essentially
postmodern culture late modern culture
we don't have an awful lot of servants
on
were rich but we might hire a cleaning
service to come in and if you think
about what a cleaning service is
actually supposed to be doing it's
producing a kind of order
among the disorder that he tend to
produce as human beings just by living
in an area we're working in an area
janitorial staff coming into a workplace
at night usually when everybody else is
away are producing a kind of order
that's similar to that in a household
there's all sorts of other things you
know the food production and
manufacturing can roll into household as
well much of that was done within the
household in ancient societies but there
are some things that are occurring that
are distinctive to the domestic sphere
then think about entertainment and
pleasure you know if we have musicians
musicians have not always enjoyed a high
social status as a matter of fact the
celebrity status that we Accord to
musicians is something relatively new
and it's not according to most musicians
you know try to go going into a place
and just playing on open mic night and
you'll see that you don't really matter
all that much except insofar as you as a
producer can give pleasure to your
audience in that case I don't want to
you know say in every case that's
master-slave dialectic for pro audiences
and performers but there is something
like that going on within this setting
so in all of these cases what we have is
that the Lord relates himself mediated
lead to the bond has been through a
thing that is independent now this thing
is what holds he says the bondsman the
slave in their servitude it is the fact
that they have to work that puts them in
the position that they are and that they
have to work on the object they become
defined in terms of the object of hogg
which they are working and if they do
this for long enough they may come to
identify their entire self consciousness
with the
kind of producer or the kind of worker
which they are I am just a peasant I I
produce food I am just a guild
manufacturer I produce glass or produce
you know whatever else well woven
fabrics I am just a household servant I
tidy things up I make sure that
everything is in its proper place I
respond to the requirements of the
master or the mistress of the house I am
an entertainer I am here to to provide
pleasure in a certain way that I've
learned how to do using instruments
working upon things so he goes on and he
says it's the chain from which he could
not break free and the struggle and
don't worry so much about the chain the
chain is just the first of the things
that the slave encounters the slave
encounters the entire world of things
upon which he or she must work and he
says this proves him to be dependent to
possess his independence and things so
the slave is in this very ambiguous
position it is so far as he's dependent
he is dependent upon the Lord Tom the
master the master is like I said setting
the agenda determining what he's going
to work upon insofar as he's independent
he is independent in the way that a
thing is insofar as he resists the
master insofar as he requires some some
tutelage insofar as he requires some
discipline whatever it is that's going
to be that resists the the rule of the
master he is independent but he's
independent only like the world of the
things upon which he works so the
stableboy does not sleep with everybody
else the stableboy sleeps in the stable
and that's a sign sort of index of the
fact that he belongs there
for the masters so he goes on he says
the Lord is the power over this thing
why now it's not just
that the Lord happens to have been born
in the right class or the Lord was in
the right place at the right time or he
popped somebody on the head and you know
produced them as a slave you got the
drop on them rather except the Lord and
this is what might make us get applause
about way who might actually be a lord
and who might not again think about
Aristotle the true master is pretty rare
the master in this case is the one who
has been willing to risk death and being
willing to risk death meant that while
having a relationship of desire to the
whole world of things the master was
also willing to dispense with them to
say I'm going to give those up I'm going
to take the chance that I'm not a mean
to be around to enjoy them because
that's how much having self certainty
knowing who I am
gaining recognition that's how much it
matters to me
so the Lord is you know in a certain
respect this is going to be a very
flowery way of expressing it somebody
who has a kind of metaphysical faith
they were hope rather they are willing
to to go to the limit because they think
there may be something beyond it and
this relationship is what turns out to
be beyond it so he says he is the power
over this thing and this again is the
power over the other it follows that he
holds the other in subjection equally
the Lord relates himself this is very
important immediately to the thing
through the bondsman so now let me see
this part of the mediation going up the
Lord doesn't have a direct relationship
to the thing in its entirety in all of
its dimensions in any of these examples
the Lord only knows part of what's going
on now the Lord's are the one who write
the history who you know get to decide
what you know Collins's what and and all
that but that means that there's an
epistemological
certainty here that is going to be
explored through the rest of the work so
he says the bondsman has self
consciousness in general also relates
himself negatively to the thing takes
away its independence how does he take
away the independence of the thing well
again let's think about these examples
agriculture or a food production you're
taking the thing and you're making it do
something that it might you know have
some inclination to do you plant a seed
and the seed does want to sprout but
that seed didn't necessarily want to
sprout in that furrow
so that you could then harvest it later
on right that's not part of the inherent
teleology a chickpea Singh chickpeas
were one of the early cultivated
foodstuffs in the Mediterranean area so
the same thing with manufacturing you
take sand that sand does not by itself
want to be glass let alone be a glass
bottle in this shape colored a certain
color and then shipped over here or
given to this this particular owner or
master or a procurer the slave is is
taking the things of nature and the
things of culture and making them obey
their own will but it's not just the
will of the slave right because it's the
master like I said who is determining
things who is deciding what things the
slave is going to work upon so the thing
does have both independent and dependent
aspects to it and this is part of what
we want to explore as we go through the
rest of this passage he says he takes
away the indepence of the thing but the
thing is still independent
with respect to the bondsman his
negating of it cannot go the length of
being altogether done with it to the
point of annihilation he works on it so
although you know in the fields perhaps
the slave steals a few apples or eat
some of the the peas that are growing
I remember as a child my mother was
constantly getting on us get into
weeding in the garden I'm not saying my
mother was a master and I was a slave by
the way but we had a communal garden for
the family and we had to do reading and
you know we we had only certain times
that would eat during the day we didn't
get a lot of snacks and sweet peas are
indeed very sweet so you can pick them
and we'd also take green beans and
yellow beans and we'd eat them and then
we get yelled at right same thing when
we go and pick berries like blackberries
or blueberries you know we'd be told
look we're picking these so that we can
actually do something with them now so
that you can just stop your face and
enjoy yourself in the moment with them
as the person who is doing the work
where we were actually going to can most
of it now the slave doesn't get to do an
awful lot of it they don't have the same
relationship of enjoyment that the
master does with respect to the object
instead what they do is they work upon
it the German for those but our vices
are bite is is work you know that's the
labor that you you do that you invest in
things this the slave believers the
cognate actually works here but Labor's
the thing to transform it into something
for the the master into a product so he
says slave is not actually able to do
what the master gets to do what what
self consciousness would like to do with
the thing he doesn't get to enjoy it he
works upon it the lordy says by contrast
enjoys the thing he says the immediate
relation becomes through this mediation
the sheer negation of the thing why does
Hegel consider enjoyment a negation
that's an interesting question to bring
up well when you are enjoying something
for the most part you are making it
other than what it is you are consuming
it in the process with food this is very
simple right
eat the food you taste the food the food
food items are very interesting because
even if they are works of art they're
works of art that only do the work of
that that an artwork does if you
actually eat them up and that's gone
then somebody else can't do it you can
take as many you know shots as you like
and put it on Instagram but the picture
of the food is not the same thing as the
food right presentation is only part of
it flavor
you only get by putting it in your mouth
and keeping it where I suppose you know
Modernist Cuisine they deconstruct
things there's a whole conversation that
can be had there when you get the idea
the master treats the thing in a
negative relation but interestingly the
master doesn't grasp the whole thing
they only grasp the dependent aspect of
the thing it's the services who
encounters the independent the aspect of
the thing and they do so precisely by
having to run into it by having to work
upon it by having to deal with it as we
say in the workplace so there's a
bifurcation in the knowledge or the
experience that's being had between the
out of the master and slave he says what
desire failed to achieve the master
succeeds and do it to have done with the
thing altogether only to have done with
the dependent aspect of it done to
achieve satisfaction in the enjoyment of
it but this is a momentary satisfaction
this is not a satisfaction that is going
to last forever as we're gonna see in
the subsequent paragraphs it says desire
failed to do this because of the things
independence the world resists us the
world is independent of us but the Lord
has taken to himself only the dependent
aspect by having the bondsmen slave who
is actually able to separate these
aspects out Hegel doesn't use that that
terminology but that's something that we
need to read into this he says the
bondsman is interposed between the thing
and the master so the master key
to himself only the dependent aspect of
the thing and has the pure enjoyment of
it the aspect of its independence he
leaves to the bondsman who works upon it
so again like I just said we have a
splitting that's taking place within
consciousness in relation to the thing
which isn't just a thing it's an entire
world of things so the question that we
want to keep in mind as we're going
forward is who is really grasping
reality more the master who seems to be
you know enjoying the best of everything
right now where is it the slave
you